in this video we're going to talk about
food webs which is really just a way of
picturing how all of the matter
and how all of the energy flows inside
of an ecosystem now when i talk about
matter i'm talking about the atoms in an
ecosystem the molecules when you look at
your hand it is made up of atoms and it
turns out that the matter is not created
or destroyed it's just recycled
throughout an ecosystem and we're going
to see that in a second and then when we
talk about energy it's the energy that
your cells need to be alive the energy
you need to be alive to not just
exist but to do things to think to move
and so this food web essentially
describes that as we've talked about in
other videos in most ecosystems the
great majority of the energy in an
ecosystem comes from the sun
so what we have here is the sun produces
energy it travels to earth
and then you have organisms which we
would call producers
that are able to take that light energy
from the sun and then take atoms and
molecules from its environment things
like carbon dioxide in the air things
like water and other nutrients and it's
able to construct itself using that
energy from the sun now when it
constructs itself it not only gives its
structure but it's also able to store
energy and right over here we have
several producers depicted we have this
tree here which is able to do
photosynthesis we have the grass here
that's able to do photosynthesis and
it's not just plants you have things
like algae and other microorganisms that
are able to be producers
but then we have things like this bunny
and this bunny is not able to harness
energy from the sun by itself in order
for it to get its energy and its matter
it needs to eat one of these producers
probably some of this grass
and so we would call this bunny right
over here this rabbit we would call it a
consumer and it is a consumer you could
think of it as both matter and energy
when it eats that plant those atoms are
then able to make up the bunny it will
poop out a little bit so some of the
matter might end up right over here but
then also there is energy that is stored
in those molecules and that rabbit can
use that energy to exist and live but as
it does it it does release some of the
energy in the form of heat
and actually even producers need to use
energy in order to live and as they do
that they also release heat
now we have this fox the fox is not a
vegetarian it does not eat grass it does
not eat trees it likes to eat things
like squirrels and bunnies but big
picture it's not producing its own food
it's consuming food so it also is a
consumer we can differentiate more in
the future between things that eat
plants and things that eat other animals
and you can see in this food web we draw
an arrow from the thing that is being
consumed the thing that is doing the
consuming so a rabbit consumes a plant
and so the arrow goes from the plant to
the rabbit
a fox consumes a rabbit or a squirrel so
an arrow goes from the rabbit or the
squirrel to the fox
now some of you might have noticed that
we have these arrows that are pointing
downward and so let me scroll down a
little bit and we see these micro
organisms the worms the fungi the
mushrooms right over here and we call
these decomposers
now what decomposers are really doing is
what would you imagine breaking down all
of the things that might die the poop
that is falling down and by doing that
it's continuing to recycle that matter
and when it decomposes those atoms are
released back into the soil or the
atmosphere and then that can be reused
by the producers and once again every
organism in this food web is using some
of the energy in order to exist and do
its and do whatever it needs to do and
some of that energy is being released as
heat in every single situation